is that deja vu nope
it's one division the most recent
episode brought us all the reruns of
wanda's past
finally explaining why one division paid
tribute to so many sitcoms
how many sitcoms did the show reference
which episode is connected to olson's
personal past
let's check out the greatest reruns hits
bravo
to say wanda faced difficulties growing
up is an understatement
episode 8 highlighted the traumatic
events of her life over the years and
in the midst of her world falling apart
sitcoms were what brought her comfort
every time from losing her parents to
being stuck in a containment cell to
losing pietro
sitcoms were the one constant when the
grief became too much her powers took
over and she brought herself
right back to the greatest comfort she
always knew
yes
episode 7 brought us into the modern era
with references to two of the most
popular and uniquely shot tv shows of
this time
modern family and the office look at
this
opening
[Music]
does the jingle sound familiar
it should since it's the same one used
for the office opening credits
with slight alterations the wanda mug is
also a direct nod to the world's
greatest boss bug that belongs to
michael scott
then of course that title card a perfect
reflection of the modern family opening
title card
wanda gives off major claire dunphy
vibes with her direct addresses and
confessional style scenes
they absolutely look like they could be
in modern family
not only are they shot in the same way
but even the manner of speaking is
reflected
who doesn't love a good side eye
thankfully wandavision brought this
popular trope from the office and used
it to bring some great moments to life
in the episode
agnes slayed that sassy side glance
the closing credits in this episode are
a clear nod to the simple and clean
aesthetic of the credits of modern
family with similar fonts and colors
while this episode reflected the tv
shows of this era agatha was the cause
for a small throwback to a few decades
earlier with her theme song
agatha's new theme is just like the one
from the 60s american sitcom called the
monsters
it was catchy then and agatha has made
it catchy for us now
oh you don't have to worry about your
mom
any 90s fans will recognize the
self-videotaping style opening of
malcolm in the middle that's used for
the opening credits of this one division
episode
everything from the image quality to the
tone of the song to the fonts used are
spot on a welcome dose of nostalgia and
fun way to kick off the episode
one of the best parts of malcolm in the
middle was getting the chance to see
frankie muniz and the other kids break
the fourth wall and directly address the
camera with their hilarious remarks it
was so fantastic to see that tradition
carried on for wanda's boys billy and
tommy
we can only imagine how much fun these
two had performing these scenes for one
division
later in the episode the neighborhood
that wanda and her family go
trick-or-treating and looks mysteriously
familiar
it must be because it's just like the
main neighborhood stars hollow from the
show gilmore girls
the show was clever in making sure that
even the camera angles and shots they
used were reminiscent of the tv shows of
the era
halloween's about candy and scaring
people but mostly candy
[Music]
a bit of elizabeth olsen's past made a
special appearance in wandavision
the classic sitcom that made the olson's
older twin sisters famous
full house olson actually made a cameo
herself in the series finale of that
show
the opening credits are just like that
of full house
notice the photos of each character
aging up it's a charming intro and nod
to the classic sitcom
of course at the end we have the very
memorable
running in the park sequence which any
full house fan will know is a direct
homage to the fun and extensive opening
credits
fast forward a bit to the way the
episode starts with the focus on the
exterior of the house and then moving in
look familiar that's because it is
it's just like they used to frame and
begin many episodes of full house and a
lot of other popular sitcoms of the era
it's also pretty hard to ignore how
similar the costumes are between the two
shows
wanda looks like she was plucked right
off of the set of full house
which in a way she was only many many
years later
another familiar image is the living
room set which recreated the living room
from the show family ties
very impressively while they aren't
exactly the same
it's totally believable that these rooms
would be in the same house
so much deja vu and maybe you don't have
to either
one division and the brady bunch now
both in color just look at how well
those fonts match
right down to the rainbow colored in
color section
marvel also gives a clever non this
opening to the tile style image of the
brady bunch opening
one easter egg included in the episode
is a pretty special one
the doll the vision has is exactly the
same one that little cindy of the brady
bunch has
it's unmistakable that is definitely a
kitty carry-all
not only was the doll on the show but it
was a very popular toy of the era
when it came to settings wandavision
nailed replicating the staircase seen in
the brady bunch house
who knows what will happen when the real
thing starts
this episode brought all kinds of
familiar magic to screen
one of the most obvious nods to old
sitcoms was the animated opening with a
cartoon wanda and vision soaring through
the air
just like these opening animated credits
from bewitched
not to mention this perfectly imitated
title card
as far as imitation goes let's have a
look at this perfect kiss
looks eerily similar to the smooch from
i dream of genie
for those who may have been curious as
to why vision and wanda wake up in
separate beds at the beginning of the
episode
the answer is this the creators not only
highlighted and referenced familiar
scenes and images from the classics
but were authentic to the time period
that they took place
the separate beds was traditional
practice for the 50's era and the
opening scene is a small nod to that
then there was that moment that vision
and everything around him turned to
color
an acknowledgment of how the technology
developed and many of the beloved shows
that were once in black and white
shifted to being broadcast in color
exactly
as you are
the visual similarities between episode
1 and the classic i love lucy
are uncanny two of the obvious
connections are the aspect ratio and
black and white images
one division dives much further than
that though check out these opening
credits for example
font look familiar they've got that one
spot on
not only that but the closing credits
before we come out of the tv
also match the font of i love lucy while
the wedding dress wanda wears may not be
exactly the same as the one lucy wears
it's definitely a close match especially
the veil and hair updo
there were a few hints as to what was to
come with the magical elements of wanda
in the kitchen
it's hard not to see the similarities
between one division and i dream of
genie
after seeing this it's obvious both
wanda
and jeannie are the ones in charge the
episode also paid homage to the set of
the dick van dyke show
notice how their living rooms look
almost exactly the same
this was definitely paid attention to
with great detail and care
the similar brick backdrop and fireplace
are no coincidence
audiences were given a bit of a bonus
homage to tv history with the appearance
of deborah jo rupp in some wandevision
episodes
rup rose to fame in the sitcom that 70s
show
her appearance in the series is pretty
appropriate considering she was a star
in a show that took place in an
earlier era from when it was being shot
we're sure she had some helpful hints
for elizabeth olsen to help her nail
that performance
my head is starting to feel woozy
learning the reason for the sitcom
format that the show took on has made us
appreciate what marvel has done with
wandavision so much more
all of the sitcom throwbacks were
entertaining but knowing what they meant
to wanda brings us a whole new
appreciation is that deja vu
yes yes it is it's one division